[Music]
you can put opponents to sleep I find
that absolutely fascinating is that your
favorite way to win well it's what it's
one of my favorite ways to win
absolutely I like to knock people out
and I like to choke people out anything
that puts people to sleep okay
you vicious vicious person right when
you defeat Holly Holm it--we okay and
you choke her out and she passes out
first of all how long is she out for
that depends how long it's held for so
it takes about six seconds usually to
put someone to sleep you could do it in
six seconds yeah that's amazing
cut off the carotid artery the blood the
other blood supply to the brain right
arteries
there hasn't been blood in my brain and
I think I could defeat you I'd be there
just talking idiocy singing a fake
Edelweiss in jail you'd be like this but
no blood in his brain for two hours and
and it's so weird because fans you
actually have fans that ask you they say
please Misha do that hold on me and put
me to sleep is that right that's right
have you ever done it yeah you have
actually usually to my friends I'm that
kind of friend
yeah um so I have this friend of mine
who's like a 275 pound bodybuilder like
6 foot 4 big guy he's like I would just
grab your arm and pull it off with like
one of my arms I'm like well let's see
let me put you in this choke and let's
see and they put him to sleep that's
fantastic that's great so it really does
it works instantaneously it's just
amazing right it'd be where this almost
feels like if someone was having a hard
time sleeping and they asked you would
you help me out
I think it's putting him to sleep I
think it's a bit of a soft sell cuz it's
like you're not really sleeping it's
kind of more a mini :
you're giving them a micro stroke
you